man
what a report
hey welcome in to market takes this is
the live stream i am dion robowen a
reporter for the wall street journal
thank you all for tuning in to this
broadcast we got a big
very unexpected very i guess exciting is
one word you could use for worrisome
troubling
uh definitely something that folks out
there in the market are going to be
talking a lot about i am talking about
the consumer price index report for june
just came out this morning uh
well above expectations
not a single economist at the major bank
city
bmp parabah
credit suisse
j.p morgan not one of them predicted
inflation would be this high 9.1 percent
for cpi in june we are going to get into
all of that break down what it means why
it matters
and i think the biggest question you
know i see a lot of people on twitter a
lot of folks on tv going all kermit arms
right now about this report but the
biggest question on my mind is where do
we go from here because this report is
what it is it tells us that inflation
most certainly did not peak back in
march when the federal reserve and a lot
of economists were saying well we think
we've hit the top wasn't the top
we know that we know that much now for
sure and an economy and inflation has
continued to move higher and higher but
where do we go from here and we are
going to talk about
just where that is why that is what that
is how that is
all that right here on market take so
thank you again so much for tuning in i
think look the biggest questions that
we're going to be talking about today is
what the cpi report told us we're going
to look at the headline cpi results
versus the expectations
what this tells us about the trend
looking back and looking forward how
this could impact the federal reserve i
think that's probably the biggest
question out there and what this report
tells us about the state of the economy
again all this data is on a lag we are
looking at the report for june but what
does this tell us about july about
august about december and about 2023
2024 in the future because we learned a
lot from this report based on uh what we
got versus what was expected so
let's jump right into it um
cpi 9.1 versus 8.8
expected economists had already
predicted that we were going to see
inflation pick up from where it was in
may to june that again was unexpected
because we were supposed to have peaked
in march according to a lot of
economists but based on a lot of the
data that was coming in economists were
saying you know what we think inflation
actually rose from may to june most
economists were predicting inflation
right around that 8.8 8.9 level like i
said not a single economist at any of
the major banks predicted it would be
above nine uh or even at nine and we did
see that so
the big news here is cpi again bucking
the expectations and bucking the trend
that the fed had predicted and that we
were you know really economists were
saying that we needed to see
four things to get started because until
you start moving in until you stop
moving in one direction you can't start
moving back in the other direction the
fed wants two percent inflation and
right now we are at nine percent and
potentially rising 9.1 percent really if
you want to get into it um let's dig
into the numbers now a lot of people
have been talking about 9.1 percent
that's year over year so basically cpi
inflation was 9.1 percent higher in june
than it was in june of 2021 but month
over month just looking at june compared
to may
inflation on the cpi was up 1.3
now that is the biggest increase we've
seen on cpi since october 2005 and what
that means is that the pace of inflation
just last month rose at the fastest it's
been since october of 2005. that's a big
deal i don't think enough people are
talking about that big increase there
was an expectation for a 1.1 percent
increase we got an even bigger increase
and like i said the highest the biggest
increase we've seen in almost 17 years
now this is two straight months of
inflation month over month going up by
at least one percent and we've seen it
three of the last four months so again
we're talking about the trend the trend
is showing us that inflation is picking
up pace not slowing down not
decelerating it's actually increasing
and now it's hit this 1.3 percent point
that's a big deal
again that tells us if you look at what
we've seen from oil prices gas prices
those were a big piece of the increase
in inflation
last month however
we've seen those oil prices decline we
are now well below
100 a barrel on gasoline right or on oil
prices excuse me now well below 100 a
barrel on oil so the price of gas at the
pump we've seen that coming down and
coming down pretty precipitously
it that hasn't been factored into the
report yet those things have really been
happening over the past two three weeks
this is numbers from june where we saw
those gas prices and oil prices
continued continuing to accelerate up
around 120 a barrel for oil um
now we thought we had peaked in march
because we were seeing about the same
thing in april you saw those oil prices
start to come down gas prices start to
come down a little bit then they picked
right back up and we see where we are
now in june uh another big piece of the
of the question about where do we go
from here core cpi was 5.9 now that's
down from the previous month and may
core inflation
core cpi inflation was six percent uh in
june it was 5.9 now that's lower but not
as much lower as economists had
predicted um so we're seeing a decrease
from the on the year-over-year rate in
terms of core inflation that strips out
food and energy prices and as we said
energy has been one of the biggest
contributors i think 41.6
energy prices have risen from june of
2022 from june of 2021 uh so that's a
big part but we are seeing that core cpi
price which strips out food and energy
which have been the big
movers here
still at an elevated level um
and so that's a big big deal now if you
look at food prices i know food is very
volatile but food has actually been
pretty consistent food prices have risen
one percent in four of the last six
months and those two months of the last
six months in this year that it wasn't
up one percent it was up point nine
percent so we've seen food prices just
kind of consistently taking up higher
they haven't been very volatile hasn't
jumped around it's been right around
that one percent increase pretty
consistently every month the other piece
of this when we talk about core
inflation is the shelter portion of the
index now shelter is just how much do
you pay for rent or owner equivalent
rent oer if you want to be a nerd about
it but just what are you paying to live
in your house to have shelter right well
we've seen those prices consistently
picking up as well the other piece this
is those get slowly factored in so the
big increase we've seen in housing
prices the big increase we've seen in
rates that hasn't really gotten factored
in you know i was recently on a panel
actually with jeff hill he is the uh the
associate commissioner for prices and
living conditions at the bureau of labor
statistics and i asked him i asked him a
simple question i said jeff
if i was going to tell people you know
we
folks who watch this data know that the
data on shelter comes in kind of slowly
that it it's reported with a lag if i
was going to explain that to them in a
simple way how would you say i do that
and jeff said to me
nah player there's not really a simple
way to do it um his his response was
pretty simply that bls does the best
they can they go out there and they try
to interview people and they ask them
this is all done by surveys they go
door-to-door sometimes make calls
sometimes they say hey what's your rent
this year versus what was it last year
how much has it gone up what's the
difference in what you're paying
bls right now is short staffed they're
working on a number of different things
and they get to these things when they
get to them was basically his answer you
know that's my version of his answer but
basically what he was saying was we're
not really sure when this shelter
component when the big increase we've
seen in housing prices is going to be
reflected in the shelter component of
cpi because things just take time so we
could see a big pickup in the price of
shelter as the year goes on because as
we have seen housing prices are at all
time highs and with mortgage rates up
that's increasing those prices the
monthly rates even more yes home prices
are going down but the price you're
actually paying for that house with
mortgage rates now at five point three
percent versus three percent where they
were just earlier this year you're
paying a lot more and as a landlord as
an owner if you've got tenants you're
going to be passing that cost on to them
fed chair jerome powell at the fed's
last conference talked about how you
know core prices don't really matter to
regular people but they're what the fed
focuses on because it's the peace that
they think they control they can most
control and fed governor christopher
waller last week at a conference with
the national association for business
economics said that core cpi can kind of
be thought of as a forecast of future
inflation well core cpi is coming down
but month over month it actually ticked
higher last month so core cpi that you
know stripping out energy and food which
have been the most consistent increase
increases in the cpi report that's still
rising on a month over month level um
and and that's something that we
definitely need to be taking stock of
and keep an eye on look i want to thank
all the new viewers who have tuned in
appreciate you guys being with us here
on market takes we are going through
today's cpi inflation report a a big one
a massive one i think something that's
clearly out there moving markets right
now and we'll continue to we're going to
get into that in just a minute so the
big question here another big question
how does this impact the federal reserve
i already told you they at their last
meeting they pointed to the cpi report
that was lower than this one and they
said look that caused us to raise rates
by 75 basis points three times the
normal rate that they raise rates at
well
gonna be hard for them not to do that
again at their meeting in july and again
their meeting is exactly two weeks from
today it starts on june on july 20 on
july 27th they'll be talking to us the
in the media on july 28th powell will be
doing his press conference they'll be
releasing their statement on the 28th
but they don't have a lot of time to
come out and speak to the public to
change any sort of reaction so a 75
basis point likely locked in for the
next fed meeting
the fed fund futures market which is
where investors can bet on these sort of
things where they're putting money down
uh there were a there is a zero percent
chance of a rate hike less than 75 75
basis points zero percent not a zip
zilch no no one thinks that literally no
one thinks that the rate hike will be
less than 75 basis points at this
meeting and there is now a 44 chance
according to fed fund futures that we're
going to see a 100 basis point rate
increase that's raising rates by one
percent so again right now at the top
end we're at 1.75 percent a lot of folks
in the market a plurality of folks let's
say are starting to bet that we see a
100 basis point rate hike which takes
rates up to 2.75
the area the fed has said is the neutral
rate give or take um of where you know
it's not restrictive or accommodative
policy they're just you know neutral
they said they wanted to get there by
year end according to some folks in the
market they're going to get there by
this month uh investors had seen a 50
chance that rates were going to be about
3.5 percent to 3.75 percent by year-end
and a 50 chance they'd be at 3.25 throw
it out the window investors are now
saying nope uh 80 chance now of three
and a half percent 33 chance 3.75 and
even a 10 chance of 4 look all that
means is rates are expected to be much
higher by the end of the year
a lot of that having to do with this
high inflation report that we are seeing
inflation's still hot getting hotter
we may have peaked though the good thing
about a very high number is that it may
be the top but again let's not get ahead
of ourselves let's not do what folks did
back in march when they said oh well
that's so high we've seen gas prices
coming down we've seen oil prices coming
down this is the top no more let's not
do that let's keep in mind that prices
could keep going up from here the
biggest takeaway for the economy
right now is that inflation is probably
going to last for some time we had
factored this in but we had factored
that in with inflation
peaking in march and then kind of coming
down on this slow path well if inflation
is peaked in july it's now peaked later
and it's peaked higher and that's the
best case scenario for inflation is that
it's peaked and now it's going to come
down we are still very far away from the
fed's 2 target which means they've got a
lot of work to do and they're probably
going to have to be raising rates
they've talked about front loading rates
which means raising rates by a lot more
earlier on and they're likely going to
have to continue doing that this month
maybe their next meeting in september as
well look if we look out at the market
the stock market has very clearly not
taken this well i look at wsj.com i'm
looking at the dow the nasdaq the s p
the dow is actually taken at the worst
it's down one point one percent right
now uh the s p down about one percent
the nasdaq down about point eight
percent so we're seeing tech stocks
which have been the most volatile mover
usually when the market goes down tech
stocks go down by the most the dow goes
down by the lease when it goes up you
get the inverse tech stocks up by the
most dow up by the lease the dow is
taking this thing the hardest now down
about 1.2 percent so we're seeing a
sustained move down in the stock market
and especially in the dow jones
industrial average uh on the on the bond
side which again is the market you
really should be watching if you want to
know what's going on uh with the market
and what's important in the economy
look we saw a deeper inversion of the
two-year 10-year yield curve the
two-year is now about 15 basis points
below the 10-year that's the biggest
inversion we've seen since 2005. so we
haven't seen the yield curve this
inverted with two-year rates this much
above 10-year rate which is a signal of
recession that's happened every single
time before every single recession going
back to the 1970s
we haven't seen a yield curve inversion
this far since 2005 been about 17 years
since we've seen that so that's a big
deal when you look out at the the
current the currency market dollar euro
parity happened today one-to-one if you
got plans for a european vacation
might be a good time right now it's one
to one dollar to euro
we saw that happen the dollar has
continued to strengthen we are seeing
the wsj
dollar index rising close to 100 that's
a significant number it compares the
dollar across multiple i think it's 16
different currencies and we're seeing
the dollar strength and really across
the board a stronger dollar as we
approach earnings season watch out for
companies that don't hit their earnings
reports to start pointing to that
stronger dollar oh well you know we had
a great sale but the stronger dollar
really just hurt us in overseas markets
look out for a lot of that talk coming
from this coming current cur ad this
coming earnings season
also commodities we are seeing oil
prices continue to trend lower
across the board really oil actually
just went positive for the day but uh
wti crude is about it's about 96 brent
crude at about 99 right now still well
below holding below that hundred dollar
a barrel range but gold down silver down
copper down remember dr copper that
takes the economy's temperature
really across the board we're seeing
commodities come down
another strong signal of recession fears
in the market
um
look
we we see where we are we know we've
gone the market is very afraid right now
the market sees this and there is fear
out there and investors are reacting
accordingly uh that's going to wrap it
up i think for us here on market takes i
want to thank everybody for tuning in
with us uh like i said we're going to
wrap it up the market is showing us
clear recession fears
this signals inflation may have peaked
but it may not have keep that in mind
there is the likelihood and the very
real possibility that inflation
continues to go higher from here even
though some of those oil prices have
started to come down the biggest
takeaway is likely the fed higher rates
higher for longer and continued rate
increases we'll have to watch i thank
you guys for watching us here on market
takes and being with us i am dion rabone
reporter for the wall street journal
come back be with us we are going to
continue to do these live streams i'm
going to continue to come out break down
the data for you tell it what it mean
tell you what it means and why it
matters and i hope you'll be with us
next time right here on market takes